toutes les chansons parlent d'amour très
bien commençons par les chansons sur le
désir est lente
quand on a du mal à trouver l'amour
quand on se noie dans l'interview il
nous brise le coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis vraiment désolé pardon toutes
les chansons qu'on écoute
elles nous disent moi aimons nous moi
c'est ça je m'appelle et me
c'était simple rencontrer quelqu'un dans
la rue
[Musique]
et on sentait
son teint couper les poils qui se
hérissent une poussée d'adrénaline
nous pensons touraine on l'a ressenti
tout l'école est carrément trop génial
hommage et je suis content de fautes loi
parce que cet homme que tu vois là et
mais quand on écoute une chanson pour la
première fois elle remue des choses
juste ici
beaucoup
[Musique]
des artistes pas vrai
priori n'est jamais parfaite je crois
plus du tour la perfection ce que je
veux c'est la pagaille
question de l'harmonie t pour ça il faut
prendre les bons et les mauvais
[Musique]
mais il ya eu un maximum je t'aime
j'avais simplement peur que notre
relation n'est plus le moindre intérêt
pour toi ce que je veux dit que ça
marche
se taire les voix des autres écoutent
latine ce qui doit arriver arrive point
barre
ce que je veux
raté côté petit rebond source
[Musique]
alors chanté que vous soyez triste que
vous soyez heureux que vous soyez
croyante
[Musique]
pensons-nous défi elle raconte
l'histoire de ce qu'on a et b